In a world first, a terminally ill man in the U.S....
...has received a heart transplant from a genetically modified pig.
Doctors say 57-year-old David Bennett of Maryland is doing well...
...three days after the experimental procedure.
The surgery took seven hours...
...and was performed by a team at the University of Maryland Medicine.
It was seen as the last hope for Bennett,...
...who had been suffering from terminal heart disease.
That meant doctors were able to receive an emergency authorization for the operation from the FDA.
Dr. Bartley Griffith was Bennett's surgeon.
He's awake.
He is recovering and speaking to his caregivers...
...and we hope that the recovery that he is having now will continue.
We've never done this in a human...
...and I like to think that we have given him a better option...
...than what continuing his therapy would have been,...
...but whether it's a day, week, months, year, I don't know.
The pig heart was provided by Revivicor,...
...a regenerative medicine company based in Virginia.
Prior efforts at pig to human transplants have failed...
...because of genetic differences that caused organ rejection or viruses...
...that posed an infection risk.
Scientists have tackled that problem by editing away potentially harmful genes.